all right
here we are welcome to um welcome
everyone
uh to today's career webinar on imposter
syndrome
i'm meera singh ravath your career coach
i'm accompanied today by my colleague
jackie
as my support partner she'll be
assisting us at the back end and
moderating the chat for us
thank you jackie for joining and
supporting moving on to the next slide
so before we begin
let's get to know each other i see the
students have already started typing in
where they are from
so it will be lovely if all of you can
type your name and the nanodegree
and that you're pursuing and if possible
your location
so that everyone gets to know each other
and can connect later directly
i always encourage all my coaches to
visit the student hub
and carry on career hotline chat room
every day and leverage from the q a
that are being asked there and also
connect and network with other students
so please go ahead and type out your
details in the chat box
and let's see where do we have people
from
so we have people from belarus from
bangalore india from toronto canada
we have somebody from kolkata we have
ayook from turkey we have noha from
egypt we have robert from germany
and we have zubair from london lovely
keep typing your details
and um feel free to take the contact
details of each other
and you can connect with each other
later on
and see what common things you have and
what you can explore
so it will be a good opportunity for all
of you to connect and keep that
community going monique here is a
specialist on it last evening she was
there on
ask me anything coffee chat with coaches
she's great at connecting people so
it'll be lovely for all you guys to stay
connected with monique too
welcome to the webinar it's lovely to
have you here
i see dennis i see
abby from canada all right
and whom do we have okay keep typing and
in the interest of time now i'm going to
begin
so moving on to the next slide now a
quick introduction about me
i'm currently located out of india i
have close to two and a half decade of
work experience
in senior leadership roles for large
multinational firms and their captors
with focus on bfsi i'm culturally astute
with extensive experience in bringing
together global stakeholders
i'm known for mentoring coaching and
developing
high performance teams with diverse
capabilities
i have consistently nurtured teams and
developed leaders
across my tenure at previous
organizations i'm also a certified
behavior and personality practitioner
specialized in this
tools i specialize in career strategy
interviewing skills and job search so
moving on to the next slide
what are our key learnings today
and what can we expect to gather from
this webinar
so here are the four points that you can
see on the slide
we are going to learn what is imposter
syndrome so uh coincidentally i was
talking to a few students this morning
during the coaching session
and i asked some of them do you know
what's imposter syndrome
and two out of four said no i said great
come over for the session and you will
know what it is
because knowingly or unknowingly all of
us experience this
all the time so this is going to be our
learnings today that you see on the
slide
moving on to the next slide which is the
agenda slide
this slide is listed the topics the
subjects that we are going to be
covering today now we move on to the
actual
slide which is slide number seven and
what do we have
we have a poll this is a good way to
start
uh the session because it shows how many
people have
uh are really this is a good way to
excite the students and get them
involved
so i hope most of the people have
already joined in and those who have not
they will miss this poll but there are
more holes
that they will be able to participate
i'm going to launch the poll
and here we go please take a pic
this is anonymous so you don't have to
worry at all
let's see what each one of us here today
has to say
and nobody is judging it is just to take
a sense check on what our views are
and how do we look at it we will give it
a minute for everyone to type their
responses
and let's see what the responses are so
this is looking very interesting
and um all right
please go ahead take the poll it's
anonymous totally
and even in the recording of youtube it
will not come who has typed what
even the results don't come out so it's
fantastic
i can see almost 70 people have voted
we are just waiting for a few more to
complete
there is nothing there is no reason that
we should not be answering a poll
because this really helps us to take uh
some learnings and come back to you with
more webinars related to such
subjects so i guess there is only one
person left and that would be jackie
probably you
so if you also vote we'll have a hundred
percent vote there
so you usually for jackie's webinars i
also take the polls it's interesting for
me also
to take a go at it all right so
i'm going to now end the poll and i'll
share the results
so all of you can see please type a yes
if you can see
the results so what do we have we have
21 percent who say
that they do feel like others think
that they are more competent than they
are 21
32 have voted for fairly often
five percent have rated as never
21 as rarely and 21
as sometimes so the biggest one is
fairly often as you can see that takes
the
uh show so great it's good to know what
each one of us and the beauty is
today the audiences from all over the
globe and in our own
places we may be experiencing it in a
different way
so when we go through this webinar you
will understand more about it
and you may want to take this poll again
at the end of the webinar on your own
and ask yourself if after going through
the webinar would you like to change
your opinion
sometimes it's very interesting to see
that at the beginning what we thought
and at the end of the webinar how do we
feel about it so feel free to make a
note of this question and answer it to
yourself
all right i'm going to stop the results
sharing the results now
okay and we'll get back to our
webinar so moving on to the next slide
what is impostor syndrome so whether
you're
accomplished or just starting out there
are times when you feel the pressure of
competition
creativity and the environment and mind
you
this is not just in professional life
it's even in personal life
this morning i had gone for jogging and
one of the 18 year old girls she said
would you like to take a sprint with me
now just think
what would have gone through my mind at
that moment i'm a national record holder
for athletics okay but that was in
another life
right now i don't feel i have the
endurance or the fitness
but when she said that to me the child
in me said all right
what's the harm now in that moment i
completely felt
out of depth in my mind i knew
she's going to beat me hands down
because i don't have that fitness and i
don't have the practice
now do i call that okay i'm going to
take a sprint with you and i know i'm
going to make it
now is that impostor syndrome well there
are different degrees
where you feel out of depth this is just
one mild example
when we put ourselves up when we raise
our hand to do
something where we feel we do not have
enough knowledge
experience exposure but we still want to
take a go at it
somewhere you will feel a tingling
feeling inside you will i be able to
make it
so you will feel the pressure of
competition creativity and environment
all the time there was a survey done on
how often do you feel like
others think about your competency and
we did that poll
so let's have a look and this slide is
exactly what it shows
so if you see 60 percent of the
respondents reported
that they feel like people believe they
are more competent
than they actually are and the
corresponding other figures are also
mentioned over there and i'm sure all of
you have already read this
yeah so see how it corresponds with what
whole
results we got okay all right now we
move on to the next slide
moving on to the next slide impostor
syndrome
is the overwhelming feeling that you
don't deserve your success
it convinces you that you are not as
intelligent creative or talented as you
may seem
it is the suspicion that your
achievements are down to luck
good timing or just being in the right
place at the right time
and it is accompanied by fear that one
day
you will be exposed negatively
valerie young who is an internationally
recognized expert
on impostor syndrome she says this
what's in your rule book everyone has
unconscious rules in their head about
what it means to be competent these
rules
tend to begin with words like should
always or never so if i was really
intelligent the thoughts that come
normally to each one of our minds
at different phases of our life is if i
were
really intelligent capable and competent
i
should know everything in my field i
should get it right the first time
i should excel in everything i do i
would always know the answer
i would always understand what i'm
reading i would always feel confident
i would never make a mistake i would
never be confused
and i would never need help okay your
notion of what it means to be competent
has a powerful impact on how competent
you feel
it's also at the core of imposter
feelings
so impostor syndrome can be linked to
other feelings of
self-doubt such as fear of success fear
of failure
or self-sabotage but it's not simply
another symptom of self low self
confidence
or excessive humility it involves a
constant fear
of exposure isolation and rejection
so imposter syndrome often strikes at
moments of success
starting with a new job receiving an
award or promotion or taking an extra
responsibility such as
training others starting your own
business or becoming a first-time parent
and so on
these feelings can inspire you to work
harder so as not to be unmasked
leading to further success and
recognition
and feeling like an even bigger
fraud it's a harsh word but often
they lead to downshifting this is when
you revise your goals
and become less ambitious which in turn
prevents you
from fulfilling your true potential so
moving on
the same subject continues what is
impostor syndrome
some common thoughts and feelings
associated with imposter syndrome
include you can read on the right hand
side the first one is
i must not fail now what does this
actually
mean there can be a huge amount of
pressure currently
not to fail in order to avoid being
found out
we have experienced this right from our
childhood days when we are studying in
school and we are studying in university
we want to be there at the top we want
to get the best grades
when we join the first job we want to be
out there and be known by everybody for
the right reasons
so paradoxically success
also becomes an issue as it brings the
added pressure of responsibility and
visibility
this leads to an inability to enjoy
success
next point is i feel like a fake
so imposters believe they do not deserve
success or professional accolades
and feel that somehow others have been
deceived into thinking otherwise
this goes hand in hand with the fear of
being found out
discovered or unmasked they believe they
give the impression that they are more
competent
than they are and have deep feelings
that they lack knowledge or expertise
often they believe they don't deserve a
position or a promotion
and are anxious that somebody made a
mistake
the next point is it's all down to luck
the tendency to attribute success to
luck or to other external reasons
and not to their abilities is a clear
indicator
of impostor syndrome they may typically
say or think
i just got lucky or it was a fluke
often this masks the fear that they will
not be able to succeed the next time
the next point is success is no big deal
your thinking in your mind the tendency
to downplay success
and discount it is marked in those
with impostor syndrome they might
attribute their success to it being an
easy task or having support
and often have a hard time accepting
compliments
again they think their success is down
to luck
good timing or having fooled others now
we move on to the next slide
and it's a poll again all right
i'm going to launch the second poll all
those who are not
able to uh participate in the first poll
and if they have joined late
here is your second chance i have
launched the poll
so what is the question have you or
anyone you know
experienced impostor syndrome it's an
anonymous poll
please go for it we are just trying to
see
how many people understand the subject
and how many people are here
to learn more so we have
almost 80 percent 85 percent
just two more to go all right we got 100
that that was
in less than 30 seconds amazing i'm
going to end the poll
and i am going to share the results
please type yes in the chat if you're
able to see the results
what are the results whopping 84 percent
yes and only 16
maybe do you see this is so beautiful
there is not a single person who says
no welcome to the real world all right
i'm going to stop sharing the results
and we'll go on now to learn more about
it so here we go all right
moving on to the next slide the next
agenda item
which is types of impostor syndrome so
here
are five different competence types
imposter types okay each one has its own
focus points
right the perfectionist
now what's a perfectionist someone who
sets
almost impossibly high standards
their primary focus is on how something
is done
this includes how the work is conducted
and how it turns out
one minor flaw in and then otherwise
stellar performance or 99 out of 100
equals failure and the shame so this is
one type of personality
of people who experience
imposter syndrome the perfectionist the
next type
the expert expert is a person
who expects to know everything
is the knowledge version of the he's the
knowledge
version of the perfectionist here
the primary concern is on what and how
much
you know or can do because
you expect to know everything and even a
minor lack of knowledge
denotes failure and shame so this is the
second personality type
the third type of personality which
faces imposter syndrome
is the soloist they feel they must work
alone
soloist cares mostly about who completes
the task
to make it on the achievement list it
has to be you
and you alone because you think you need
to do
and figure out everything on your own
needing help is a sign of failure
and evokes shame in this personality
type
the fourth personality type the natural
genius
he thinks everything should be easy so
natural genius also cares about
how and when accomplishments happen
but for you competence is measured in
terms of
ease and speed the fact that you have to
struggle
to master a subject or skill or that
you're not able to
bang out your masterpiece on the first
try
equals failure to them the last type of
personality type
that experience imposter syndrome is the
superman
superwoman super student kind of
personality
they feel they should excel at
everything
they measure competence based on how
many roles
they can both juggle and excel
in falling short in any role
as a parent as a partner on the home
front as a host
as a hostess as a friend as a volunteer
as a colleague as a line manager
as a boss all evoke shame because they
feel
they should be able to handle it all
perfectly
and easily interesting just type yes no
maybe whatever you feel when you go
through these slides and if you find
something
interesting and unique
moving on to the next slide here is an
interesting flow chart
and i'm going to need all your attention
because
i couldn't really blow up the picture
much more than what i have been able to
let's take a look and please share your
thoughts
what do you relate to from these options
on the slide
please type on the chat maybe one maybe
two maybe three
you know that could be so many things
that you may be able to really relate to
so if you're able to read i know it's a
small font
but try and bear your glasses and try
and read
what's written on the comments and type
what comes to your mind
this exercise was done by dr valerie
young one of the leading
experts of this field so you can read
the comments over there on the slide
so read the comments and if you think
that you are
able to relate to any of these or you
have seen somebody else relating to this
it's not that if you type something
people are going to think oh you suffer
from this no
no not at all it's just an opinion it's
just a view
have you come across any of these
comments feel free to share your
thoughts
anything similar to this anything
related to this
anything opposite of this so feel free
to read the slide
and if you can relate something you type
it on the chat
i'm going to give you a minute in case
you want to really type out something
excellent jeremy you've experienced a
few of them
in fact i'll be surprised if there is
anybody who says i have not experienced
any of this or i don't know of anybody
who has experienced any of these because
these are very very common things
and this was a huge research done you
know
uh on a very large scale and only after
that
these have been published for public to
actually go through and understand the
subject
it has become very easy today for us to
understand this subject
but a few years ago people would be
struggling to give words to the feelings
and emotions and thoughts in their mind
on imposter syndrome so i see quite
interesting comments here
somebody says i often experience the
feelings that timing and luck have lead
to
have led to success excellent i have
also felt this many times
i agree with you wise and i see
somebody has said yes to many of them
and somebody says i must figure out
everything on my own
absolutely there are moments where
you're pushed into the corner
or where it's a competition pressure you
feel why should i go and ask for help it
will show my weakness
i must figure it out on my own we all
experience it's a very normal
uh emotion that comes up you know and
bigness lar
that's really interesting absolutely
so many of us feel this that you know i
got the
success because it was bigner's luck or
somebody else got the success
because it was bigner's luck yeah and i
see somebody saying that i often feel my
colleagues are more mature
or ahead of me yes it depends on the
phase of life they are in
it depends on what they have studied it
depends from where they are coming
and that's the beauty even on this
webinar today
there are students there are
participants from all over the globe
now everybody will be having different
level of
priorities and different level of
maturity and different level of career
phases of their life
so this is bound to be experienced by
all of what all of us
and it's very normal i see somebody
interestingly saying difficulty to
delegating tasks
welcome to the real world that's the
sign of a perfectionist
all right and it's a whole huge new
subject
i may pick this up as a topic for one of
my upcoming webinars delegation
it's a very big science and art in
itself
uh setting unattainable goals
absolutely absolutely i couldn't have
agreed more
i see somebody saying that i am thinking
i'm not meeting expectations
well it's normal so i think keep
thinking about it
this slide was to help you introspect
help you relate to it help you start
understanding
because when we introspect and then we
relate to it we are able to learn more
yeah so i'm very happy with the active
engagement that's happening on the chat
keep
keep it going keep it coming all right
so in the interest of the time let's go
ahead
we are going to move to the next slide
all right symptoms of impostor syndrome
right what does the slide show us slide
shows us whopping 12 pointers
i'm going to break it down easily for
all of you the first one
you have difficulty accepting praise
while plenty of people
are not good at accepting compliments
imposters actually have trouble
internalizing their success
to the degree they can't accept praise
as valid
they are nagged by a feeling they are
not worthy of the praise
they receive or that they were
recognized in front of
more worthy peers and it is not a
display of false
modesty they truly don't believe they
deserve the duke credit
this is one of these symptoms of
impostor syndrome
second symptom you tend to discount your
success
so since those with imposter syndrome
have trouble
accepting praise as valid they have a
tendency to relate their success
to external factors or
attribute it to somewhere else entirely
this was really the result of molly's
hard work i just
helped it along has that thought come to
you ever
or have you heard this smile reading
this
or hearing this from me okay just keep
relating to what i'm saying
keep introspecting the third symptom you
are an overworker to a fault
if there were a trait of imposter
syndrome
that one can identify with the most it
would be this one over working
which is both an observed and
self-perceived pattern
of imposter syndrome okay and it is the
person's tendency
to keep investing energy and effort into
a project
long after it has reached the point
where it would be more than acceptable
to someone else
imposters recognize this pattern but
they are essentially powerless to stop
it
the next symptom you feel a compulsion
to be the best
there is a reason this phenomenon is
most
commonly attributed to overachievers
yeah many of those with imposter
syndrome were straight
a students in grade school and
upon entering higher academia or the
work world
felt a heightened compulsion to excel in
the company
of the new influx of smart and talented
people surrounding them
next you feel a compulsion to be the
best there's a reason this phenomenon
sorry you are often described as a
perfectionist
this goes hand in hand with the
compulsion to be the very best
next the fear of failure can paralyze
you
not only is failure not something you
enjoy
it's honestly not an option you have to
tell yourself that you keep yourself
from falling
into a tailspin of anxiety and doubt you
internalize failure which perpetuates
this cycle next you sometimes avoid
showing confidence
so avoiding displays of confidence plays
into an imposter feelings of inadequacy
all right next you actually dread
success in some ways
the fear of failure people with imposter
syndrome
experience in multi-pronged ways they
feel anxious about success
because they don't feel worthy they feel
guilty about success
because they drive for it often
distances themselves
from their family and peers they feel
ambivalent about it
because they recognize it may lead to
more responsibility and advancement
they are uncertain they merited in the
first place
next one you can't help comparing your
struggles
although some part of you knows and
accepts comparisons
are subjective and that everyone's
journey is different
the persistent voice in your head
assumes everyone is getting by with life
with much less struggles than you are
think about it
how many times at least once somewhere
in some point of time in life personally
or professionally
you may have thought about this next
you chalk things up to your charm
so often people with impostor syndrome
are highly intelligent and boast a great
deal of intuition about other people
they rely on their perceptiveness to
interact with others
who find them charming but because
imposters have such
deep-seated insecurities they tend to
use this charm
to cover favor with supervisors and
other authority figures
next one you focus more on what you have
not
done ah if i had a dollar for every time
i was guilty of doing this
i would be a rich woman because the
standards people with imposter syndrome
set for themselves are so high
they rarely meet the milestones they
have created
as such they dwell not all they have
accomplished
which is often a lot but instead
on what they haven't check off their
accomplishment bucket list
the last one you're convinced you're not
enough
and herein lies the hallmark of imposter
syndrome
the persistent and overwhelming feeling
that you are a phony that one day
everyone is going to wise up
and reveal there is the not so that
there is the not so great news
yeah but here are few more comforting
facts
this phenomenon is actually quite common
it afflicts both men and women
and researchers believe that up to 70 of
people have suffered from it
in some form in their lives and there
are things you can do to curb these
feelings in a healthy
proactive manner all right so don't go
worrying
your big beautiful brain about it too
much you've got enough on your mind and
you're going to see
how to cope them moving on to the next
slide a lot of
uh reading happened just now so let's do
a poll and let's relieve
ourselves from the stress a bit and get
into action
i'm going to launch the poll now and
here we go
please go for it for those who joined
late
this is an anonymous poll please feel
free
are you guys able to see the poll please
type yes no
i have launched it from my side
wow that was easy
lovely i can see 50 have taken the score
is going
up the question is which of the below
listed
outcomes of imposter syndrome impacts us
financially now is that not a very
interesting question
so ranjan you will see a poll coming up
on your screen
maybe jackie you can help him by typing
on chat how to
access the poll all right
did you even think in these terms see
this is a very beautiful poll and i came
upon this
out of my research on the subject that
how financially
impostor syndrome can impact us
so i think oh yeah we got hundred
percent
i'm going to end the poll so i'm
assuming ranjan got it how to take the
poll
thank you for participating and i'm
going to share the results please type
yes in the chat
if you're able to see the results so we
have 16 percent
saying stress costs us financially
five percent say work performance 16
percent say self-doubt
16 percent say avoid seeking promotions
21 percent say productivity loss and a
whopping 68 percent says
all of the above and you're absolutely
right
all of the above is the result of a huge
research
which i'm going to share now with you on
the next slide
so moving on to the next slide to show
you whether what we
opted for is right or we can change our
opinion
so moving to this slide you can see
how much is impostor syndrome costing
you
it's a very interesting slide and a good
research done
the credits are given at the bottom of
the slide and you can read it yourself
burn out and stress from being spread
too thin
cost the average working american a
whopping 988 dollars
tension from unrealistic goals costs an
average
two thousand to forty four dollars per
person
each year when putting your health on
the back burner
your performance follows lack of sleep
in the u.s costs 2569 dollars
per person each year decrease in
productivity and mood
costs businesses three thousand four
hundred dollars per employee each year
just by avoiding your salary talk and
not negotiating your work
can cost you seven thousand two hundred
five hundred twenty eight dollars each
year
and last but not the least on average
americans spend eighteen thousand
dollars
annually on unnecessary purchases
this income could be saved or put
towards a side hustle
now while these statistics are showing
for americans
but you could relate this individually
to your own countries as well
the figures may change but all of them
seem to be holding true
so thank you for sharing your thoughts
and thank you for participating in the
poll
and if you find anything interesting
feel free to put a comment on the chat
it's always good for the
facilitators to keep seeing how engaged
our audience is
keep going moving on to the next slide
again now now this is a interesting
slide
not much content on it it's easy on your
eyes
take a guess what percentage of people
experience imposter syndrome
in a work environment okay let's limit
it to work environment
or somebody who wants to limit it to
both personal and professional life
so just put percentage what do you think
10 20
30 in your organization in your industry
what percentage of people in your
opinion experience imposter syndrome
you all guys have participated in the
polls and you've seen the results
even if we take this population what has
your understanding been
based on this what percentage of people
wow
amazing 75 and 40
and 80 wow so
average i can see 80 to 85 percent of
the people
experience impostor syndrome is what our
audience is saying
i also have somebody saying hundred
percent yes monique
excellent i also agree with you so we
see that
um and i have an interesting response on
the chat
somebody has mentioned particularly for
it sector
wonderful i'm going to give you more
amelie
not only it sector i'm going to show you
all the sectors
based on the research and how close you
were to what you have typed
thank you very much for sharing your
thoughts all right
so i'm going to now move on to the next
slide which is exactly what it is going
to share with you
by the industry take a minute and look
at it
very interesting slide they have given
the names of the companies and you can
relate them to the industry
so you can see there are companies and
industries
who have a whopping percentage of 73
67 64 and it goes down
so i'm going to give you a minute to
absorb the data
yeah you can see the names of the
company right from
amazon to facebook to linkedin to google
to ebay to cisco to apple
if these companies are experiencing you
can imagine how many more companies and
industries are a part of it
interesting what do you think of this
research
all right moving on our time is running
out and i'm really worried moving on to
the next slide
this will be probably the last poll i
think or maybe the second last i'm not
sure
i'm launching a poll for you guys and
yeah this is almost the last poll i have
launched the poll
please feel free to take uh uh
to pick your choice what do you think is
impostor syndrome gender driven
all that we have learnt in the last 20
slides what do we
think is it gender driven
is it not do women experience it more
do men experience it more so
um i have just one more person left to
to respond and maybe that could be
jackie
jackie take your pick i would love to
know your answer
and i'm going to close the poll now
we have 99 percent i will let that one
person stay in peace
maybe he or she has not okay i got it
hundred percent
thank you guys you're a lovely audience
i'm ending the poll and i'm sharing the
results now
um 21 persons say yes
it is gender driven 47 percent say
no and 32 percent say maybe
all right thank you for your opinions we
can say close to 50
people say that imposter syndrome is
not gender driven excellent i'm going to
stop
sharing the results the next slide will
tell you uh
what the what the percentage is so here
is the next slide
now if you look at this you have the
statistics
of what females and males experience as
imposter syndrome
it's almost equal 23 of the women
experience impostor syndrome and 25
of the males experience imposter
syndrome so it's actually new to general
everybody
experiences it that's what this
statistics tells us
maybe if we do more research we can get
more details but for this webinar i
think and for the time we have
this should leave you with the thought
um provoking thought in your mind
so we move on to the next slide impact
of imposter syndrome in career and life
listed here are a few observations of
imposter syndrome
which can affect the following aspect of
a personal
of a person's life so what are they
we can see a whole list i'm going to run
through the slides at a little faster
pace because i want to give
time to you guys to even ask questions
so what performance
the person may fear that their
colleagues and supervisors expect more
from them
than they can manage they may feel
unable to deliver
this is the impact second taking on
responsibilities
people with imposter syndrome may focus
heavily
on limited tasks instead of taking it
taking on
additional duties that can prove their
abilities
according to a research published in
2014 they may avoid taking on additional
tasks
for fear that they will distract or
compromise the quality of their existing
tasks
self-doubt success and create a cycle of
self-doubt for people with imposter
syndrome
attributing success to outside factors
individuals with imposter syndrome deny
their competency
job dissatisfaction and burn out in some
cases a person may not feel sufficiently
challenged in their work
but a fear of failure or discovery
stops them from seeking promotion or
extra responsibility
avoid seeking promotions undervaluing
skills and abilities can lead those with
imposter syndrome
to deny their worth they may avoid
seeking promotion
or a raise because they do not believe
they deserve it
focus on task and goal setting a fear of
failure
and the need to be the best can
sometimes lead to over
achievement last but not the least
mental health impact
the fear of not being good enough can
lead to mental health complications
in some cases moving on to the next
slide
strategies for overcoming impostor
syndrome
that's what we are here to learn all of
us now agree
that all of us have experienced imposter
syndrome
in some shape or form so strategies is
going to help each one of us
and also the people we know it's a very
interesting subject
feel free to talk about it next time the
topic comes up
and if you are seeing anybody with this
kind of a syndrome
this will help you to have some
knowledge and some contributing
conversation on the subject so what are
the strategies
all you need is a chance to see your
life skills
toolbox to help you
overcome your impostor syndrome
and here are few techniques listed below
first one separate feelings from fact
just because you feel something does not
mean
you are just because you feel
something does not mean you are
we all feel stupid or slow or unprepared
at times
do you know how many times just before
the webinar i feel
oh have i uploaded the polls oh have i
put my slides in order
am i going to be able to complete this
in the time will i be able to give time
to the
to the participants to ask questions we
all feel stupid or slow or unprepared at
times and it's perfectly fine
yeah next stop striving to be perfect
accept that perfection is unattainable
and that no one is perfect
next welcome positive feedback and
internalize praise and don't fixate on
any negative feedback listen to the
negative feedback
and then focus on the positive yeah
attribute success truthfully the next
one
everyone has good and bad luck
attributing success to luck undermines
your abilities and confidence
be grateful and appreciative next point
forgive mistakes
mistakes are how we learn best
so recalibrate yours next
identify your rules challenge them and
rewrite
i don't have to be right i don't always
have to know the answer
i can ask for help i don't have to be
strong
so identify your rules right
the next one change your internal script
and
underlying beliefs the next time
you make a presentation say to yourself
i won't dry up everyone feels a little
unsure
when they start a new job so it's
just natural to feel this way and it
won't last
last but not the least on the slide make
a
balanced list of your strengths and
accomplishments
it's less easy to discount a success
when seen against a backdrop of past
successes
i hope this slide gives you a lot of
food for thought
and it helps you to start looking at
things with this new dimension
moving on to the next slide strategies
for overcoming impostor syndrome
continued
here are few more insights okay
and i'm going to play three slides over
here and you will see
on each slide there is on the left hand
side the theme given
all right so the theme on this one is
understand your mindset and under that
you have three sub points know the signs
we often overlook the science of
imposter
syndrome that come up in our day-to-day
lives
however recognizing these signs is the
first step towards
overcoming them pay attention to your
language choices
both when you're talking to other people
and when you're talking to yourself
especially
when it comes to talking about work
if you find your own success all the
praise
others give you uncomfortable
do some reflective thinking on where
those types of
thoughts come from and what it means
in your professional life yeah the
second point
know that you are not alone when you
have impostor syndrome
some of the most important encouragement
comes
from realizing how many hugely
successful people both male and female
have built amazing careers even while
regularly coping with it now that you
have been on this webinar
in your free time just type which are
the famous people
who have experienced imposter syndrome
and it will make a
thoroughly interesting read for you guys
the third point on the slide
embrace the feeling and use it it's
really hard
to get rid of impostor syndrome
completely especially
if you have had it for years and years
the fact that hugely successful people
like maya
angelou and don shedley feel that way
after all they have accomplished is
evidence
that it can sometimes be a lifelong
condition
that's why the best angle from which to
tackle your impostor syndrome
is not getting rid of it completely
it's stopping it from hindering your
success
moving to the next slide in this next
slide
the second theme is finding your truth
again let go of your inner perfectionist
perfectionism can be a major roadblock
for
overcoming imposter syndrome
many people who suffer from imposter
syndrome are high achievers
people who are extremely who have who
set
extremely high standards and are
committed to doing their best
and being the best at some point you
need to take a step back and ask
yourself
when is good enough
when is good enough good enough
okay when is good
enough for you the next point track
and measure your successes when you feel
like an impostor one of the hardest
things to grasp is
how much of a role you have
in your own successes you might default
them to luck or others hard work
when in fact your own work knowledge and
preparation
had a lot to do with it to help show
yourself that you're
actually doing well keep track of your
wins
in a private document there are a lot of
different ways
to track these successes and the matrix
you use
will depend entirely on your job you can
create an email folder
or whatever makes you feel good about
your hard work and preparation
okay that's a very practical way of
keeping
yourself on track the next point on the
same slide
say yes to new opportunities it is
impossible
to say yes to everything especially
when you're feeling stressed but it's
all too common for people
who have impostor syndrome to turn down
career making
opportunities because they don't
feel like they are they would do a good
job but remember
keep richard branson's famous quote in
your mind
if someone offers you an amazing
opportunity
and you are not sure you can do it say
yes
and then learn how to do it later
i will copy paste this proverb this
quote by richard on the chat so that you
can read it even after the slide moves
it's a very interesting quote moving on
to the next slide
the last slide on the agenda today build
your support
very very important step talk about it
with a mentor and your manager
or a coach sharing your thoughts and
experiences with someone else will make
you feel
better equipped to deal with your
impostor syndrome
your mentor will be able to help you
talk
candidly about your struggles with
impostor syndrome
while giving you a more objective point
of view
next point be kind to yourself take the
pressure of yourself
and stop trying to be the expert on one
day
yeah this advice was given by hubspot
marketing manager jennifer
staffonsick being kind to yourself
simply means changing the way you talk
to yourself
in your head by practicing positive
self-talk not only can it help you
become
less stress and anxious but it can also
help you build
the courage to do things that will bring
you greater rewards
last but not the least distinguish
humility and fear
there is taking humility in your hard
work and
accomplishments and then there is a
feeling
overcome with fear because of them
sometimes
simply being good at something can cause
is to discount its value but as
carl richards wrote in a new york times
article
after spending a lot of time fine tuning
our ability
isn't it sort of the point for our skill
to look and feel natural you know it's
called
unconscious competence
the levels of competence if you guys are
aware about it
it's exactly what richards carl richards
wrote
in this article i'm going to put this
statement also on the chat
for those guys who want to read this
well and understand this well
and and think about it all right so here
you go
i've put it on the chat this quote and
now
the final words and summary you may live
with imposter syndrome every day guys
it's not a reflection of who you are
it should become your internal dialogue
many of us who have worked hard are
plagued with this imposter syndrome
even though in theory we should feel
more confident
it is all because of our internal biases
our internal and past may shape our
internal biases
but it is our life skills that can fix
these internal biases
having a five step a three-step program
that we just talked in the previous
slides
in any situation when imposter syndrome
might creep up
will help you to navigate your emotional
life
the strength the strength of these
programs or techniques
is that they incorporate all of the life
skills that you already know
so practice practice these techniques as
much as you can
at the end of feeling less like an
imposter is an
opportunity to sharpen your life skills
and reclaim your sense of self
moving on to the last slide which is the
most awaited slide by some of the
students in my webinars
here are your take away links
so i am going to give it online right
now
to the participants here you go i have
given you some reading notes
reading articles resources to learn more
on the subject
all these links will also get uploaded
on youtube in the even description below
the recording
so people who are going to be actually
seeing the webinar
they need not fear that they are not
getting the resource links
it's just that the participants who have
taken the time out to be
present on the webinar now i'm giving it
away to them on the chat
moving on to the credit slide i couldn't
have done this on my own
and the credits go to all the people who
have done the research
i have picked this up from many many
many uh resources
and sources and they are all put up over
here thank you for those people who have
done this research and helped us to talk
on this subject today
moving on to the last slide question and
answer
so here we are we come to the segment of
q a
go ahead and ask away and let me try my
best to answer
as many questions as i can during the
time we have
all right i know that there is very less
time left for us
but nevertheless we'll try and do five
extra minutes over and about the time
so um do you have any questions
and if anybody had typed questions
earlier please write them now and i'll
pick them up
we can definitely pick up four or five
questions we do have that much time
so go ahead go ahead what comes to your
mind
what did you feel in the last 60 minutes
you have given 60 minutes of your time
to learn this subject
what did you experience share your
thoughts
what's on your mind is this something
you would be more comfortable talking
about
now that you know a little more and do
you think it's very normal
to experience this feeling yes no maybe
please go ahead and type it'll be lovely
to know
thank you zubair thank you for your
comment
all right okay rama
yes cooling down in medic meditation can
definitely helped
monique says what i have learned over
time is being aware of internal negative
mind talk and switching it to positive
thoughts absolutely
absolutely
jeremy has put a question privately i'm
not sure jeremy would you like me to
talk about it right now or
maybe it was a mistake that you put it
privately instead of
instead of putting it on uh to everyone
uh the question is how can we help
ourselves feel competent
for taking an industry job when we lack
a degree
just wanted to make sure you saw okay no
no jeremy i'm watching everything
all right how can we help ourselves feel
competent for taking an industry job
when we lack a degree well some things
come with experience
something comes with project work some
things come with
actually getting an opportunity while
you're doing one job and your
organization puts you into a position
where they present an opportunity to you
not for everything you need a degree
all you need is your ability to tell
your story your ability to demonstrate
your projects
your ability to show that you have
worked in live environment
using the techniques tools and
technology and at that time nobody asks
for your
degree for example when we are coaching
nobody asks us for our degree
it's what we demonstrate it's it's how
we come across it's how we communicate
and it's how we are able to display
correct so
this is a larger conversation jeremy and
if you have one-on-one
career coaching sessions available to
you please feel free to come and we will
be happy to pick this up
and also every tuesday we have asked me
anything
um events happening this will be an
interesting topic for discussion
so munich can tell you and she can even
share the link with you she was there
last evening
and please come for that event and it we
can have a great conversation on this
um i hope that helped you jeremy i see
one more question
um i found my passion in my study field
after graduating with poor grades
that's always on my mind when i
introduce myself to people and
recruiters
how can i face this okay
um all right
the student wants to remain anonymous
which is perfectly fine
um okay
not everything that we do necessarily
has to be the benchmark success in life
right nobody is going to ask you why you
scored poor grades
people are more interested in knowing
what knowledge you gathered from it
what skills you gathered from it and how
do you bring it to the table
and how are you able to help us now so
so
flip your story from a negative mindset
to a positive backdrop i am a graduate
and so and so
these are the subjects i have learned
this is how i brought it to life by
doing these projects
and i find myself being excellent and
delivering this this
flip your story and if you have a
one-on-one career coaching available
please come over this is an interesting
topic and very close to my heart
i can definitely help you in in
learning how to tell your story this
life is all about personal branding and
telling your stories
if you become good at it and it is one
of the most difficult skills to develop
and this is for all you guys learn to
tell your story
and nobody will ask you what you scored
and what degree you have
and i'm saying this out of my experience
yeah
there's one more question jackie yeah
from ireland she raised it earlier
during the session so i just wondered if
we could manage that
right thank you jackie does imposter
syndrome at some point of professional
career disappear
okay let me flip this question for you
why do you want it to
disappear invite a tip make friends with
it
and make it work positively for you some
things can help you to work
and put that adrenaline in you to do
more and yes
to answer your question straight for
some people it does disappear for those
people who
learn the techniques and the strategies
to keep working and they start having
the positive conversations
they start looking at all the negative
aspects in a positive light
and that helps them to make it disappear
from their life
i hope that helps you yeah
all right anupam says is there a good
book on this topic you would recommend
yes i'll send it to you on um
on email or on students hub is that okay
with you
i'll definitely send across to your
books
and i think i have put something as a
book even on my resource links which i
have given
and i will add one more book link to the
to the resource links on the chat
on the youtube even description
all right uh with that
knowhow do you want to say something is
there
i think i'm missing some question if i
missed anybody's question please feel
free to type
we have come to an end of this webinar i
hope you guys enjoyed this
i have thoroughly enjoyed doing a
research on this despite
being in career for 25 years of my life
and having gone through
each and every emotion and each and
every
uh symptom that i was writing here out
for you guys
i could relate to so many because i have
worked for so long with teams with
other peers and colleagues and i have
seen
different degrees of imposter syndrome
in everyone around me
and it was an amazing topic for me to
research and reconfirm to what i
believed in
i hope this helps you to take you a step
uh about this
and helps you to work on it positively
and drive
a positivity in you with this keep
coming for our future webinars it will
be a pleasure to have you
you'll have been a great audience with
the great engagement you gave stay safe
stay healthy till we meet again
thank you goodbye take care